those of us in Austin and most all of us
in Texas know John Henry Faulk loved him
dearly and we know him as a folk
humorist and a civil libertarian who
fought against Joe McCarthy in the
blacklisting the back in the 50s and we
know him as a media figure on radio
television author of books and we know
him also as a great communicator easy
Mable to to convert some redneck
sometimes to the progressive way of
thinking and that's a no easy task
he's written two books fear on trial
about his experiences during the
McCarthy era and now as they knew him
uncensored John Henry Faulk and if you
want to spend an evening just laughing
your guts out and thinking at the same
time well this is the book for you
because it has so many of the great
things that we know that the John Henry
fog we've heard him and seen him do well
it's in print now and you can and you
there's one thing in there I learned
about John he I didn't know that he was
a scholar John Henry you were a scholar
back at the University of Texas has
profound scholar a man of infinite
wisdom and scholarship always escape me
ride margin you did me that's very kind
of it just say I want to convert correct
something if I might and I plead
terrible way to start a program off of
curriculum there's an AMA convert I've
even converted rednecks you see in my
and my way of thinking there are no
rednecks per se in an ordinary sense of
what we think of rednecks
there are rednecks I know that are Phi
Beta Kappas and PhDs at the University
of Texas I know some rednecks on belongs
the president's cabinet in fact far as
I'm concerned the presidents are redneck
at times if by redneck you're referring
to people who are uninformed on the
issues and or have a very backward and
punitive attitude toward those more
positive aspects of our society
I didn't mean to correct you but I just
it ain't
converting rednecks that I've ever
engaged in what I've tried to do always
this is communicate some of the joys
being alive to people and if by that
process I somehow get some folks
thinking that way then that's more the
more the good fortune of mine we hold
that your book up there so you get a
good shot at Albany glad let me hold it
I know it's it's a vicious book and way
because not only do you read it and you
can't put it down like to say but then
you reread it you reread and you spend
so much time with another sweet thing
but so many great things in there about
humor and folk humor and I'd like to
talk with you about this craig
Hattersley and i in your book they talk
about the difference of that a folk
humorist is compared to other types a
comedian or Tom a yes what what is the
difference well I think the reason they
they refer to me as a folk humorist is
that very early in life I out in South
Austin Texas here in Travis County I
evolved a way of looking at the world it
came kind of natural to me came from my
parents really and from my neighbors who
mostly were folk folk they were my
mother for instance when I was little
boy used to say you know I wouldn't take
a million dollars for Johnny but I
wouldn't give you a dime for a dozen
more just like this this gentle put-down
you know I would oh I love to buy Johnny
for what he's worth and sell it for what
he thinks he's worth this this way of
looking at life and and gently you know
nudging you back into your when you got
too big for your britches came naturally
to me and I learned very early in life
to have to laugh at myself there was a
kind of a defensive mechanism
I was raised out in South Austin in a
very ordinary Texas household my father
was a lawyer but he fancied himself a
farmer too so we were raised on a farm
we had
Callister built we had a family of black
family that lived on our place and
looked after the heavy work for us and
daddy did his lawyer in over in Austin
he was quite a performer himself to the
influenced you and you yes he had a very
keen sense of satire and he was born
raised a sharecropper and he had the
earth he had that wonderful sense of the
Texas earth and the humor you see that
derived actually from the origins of our
society this is what very few people
realize this why Mark Twain was such a
master of it in the 19th century saw it
come to such full bloom with just
Billings and Bill Nye and others this
this use of folk imagery and folk
situations to puncture pomposity and
humbug we were born into a society the
first self-governing society on the face
of the earth in modern times you know
very few people realize this very few
people realize that the people are
sovereign and the government is servant
in our society but that is basically
what those gentlemen 200 years ago set
up the people would be the masters and
the government would be the servant this
is a powerful it's something very
powerful and those birds in Washington
forget this see and the ones in Austin
forget it and so if one of the ways we
managed a hundred years ago and
fortunately still kind of hang on
there's still a residue of it I'd like
to think that I'm a practitioner of this
if you keep them in line by said hey you
are hired hand Ronny you work for me I
don't work for you you asked for this
job you and that bird you got a pair as
your vice president the bush y'all came
in said you know how to drive us over
American bus that you all had the
blueprint to have road to prosperity at
peace and happiness you get off you
drive bus off in the short
short rolls and start bouncing daylights
out of me and my wife and children and
scaring the daylights out of the old
folks and we tap you on show and say run
and get back up on the highway where he
said she's going to drive take us that
peace and prosperity all this war
mongering you're doing around the world
willing to kick the daylights out
anybody don't agree with you is entire
like and you start driving away we want
you drunk
well you use the cadet Snodgrass quite
frequently as vehicle or as a medium for
evolving a political humor evolved
cousin ed Snodgrass to pretty much
embody the a point of view that's very
prevalent in this country a point of
view that after all elected Ronald
Reagan president and supports him point
of view cousin Ted for instance the
other day said Johnny there's three
great truths in this world number one
and I fight for any one of them Johnny
the first one is that Ronald Reagan's
the greatest president knew nine states
has ever had and the second one is Jesse
Helms the greatest statesman this
country has ever known and the third one
is the Earth's a flat surface
well this this is the way I come at
those two gentlemen and on the hey I let
cousin had Snodgrass do it cousin Ed's
86 years every has been mad for 80 of
them he was six years old when his mom
and daddy told him South it lost the
Civil War and he's been pouting about it
ever since got a big sign over his
fireplace Yankee beware robert e lee
might have surrendered but I ain't and
he embodies most of the philosophy and
thoughts outrage that people clear with
the you had the men ticket political
point of view you used as cutting that's
not grass real well to roasts Oh Richard
Nixon over
the in the Watergate situation in your
book you have one about cousin that's
saying that Nixon ought to get a cease
and desist order you remember yes you
know that that became a very effective
piece that I used before
bankers groups and you know conservative
groups that I spoke before I'd say now
I'm not going to this is after dick got
run out of office you know you know it
was history-making for president to
behave a practicing criminal to be
driven out of office the highest office
in the land and his vice president Spiro
Agnew was driven out to you know for
being a crook been outright crook and
Richard Nixon for being a being not only
a lie but a but a double-dyed liar you
know and a man that committed felony a
felony
you know swore to false facts to betray
the American people for such an
outrageous thing that after he kicked
out you know his stock had sunk pretty
low and all these people that were
rejoicing in him in 1974 or in 1972 when
he'd run for reelection were cooled off
considerable so I I evolved this piece
because a pleasent head Snodgrass comes
roaring over to my house and says Johnny
no if I Prichard Nixon is after he took
off for San Simeon see but left office
Gerald Ford become if I see our dick
Nixon I get me I'd go down down to the
Capitol and hire the best lawyer I could
get a hold of a Jim cracking low your
nod fly them rascal I'd swear anniver
and get a cease and desist order and
habeas corpus and all City said and I
would have her ass polish my name is
Richard Nixon better known as tricky
Dicky when I run in 1972 I run not as a
stranger but it's one of the best known
men in the
new 9-inch States of America and I'd
been known as tricky dicky for 20 years
and yet you gave me a overwhelming
mandate and he did get a little woman
when I run in 1968 I said I would in the
war in Vietnam had a secret plan for it
and four years later I'd spread it all
over the map of Southeast Asia
kill more people and done more bombing
than had been did before
and yet in 1972 after all of that you
gave me a mandate that I go down lists
about ten now you pick me up off a
running a red light called Watergate for
God's sakes look at my face
you say I'm a crook you say it can't you
can't believe me listen America you'd
better look in the mirror and say your
own face I've just been doing it the way
you wanted it done that so I'm a
reflection of you oh you could sit in
the audience
tear it it's hair you know better than
the one I'm it voted for him though I
knew and everything he was saying was
absolutely true there after that you
wrote a piece and this is a some kind of
precedence I think because it was 73 74
he wrote a piece about Ronald Reagan why
he was the perfect esident it was
prophetic was it really where I thought
about yeah I couldn't it's not grace
comes roaring over to my house that
morning and dick had been kicked out of
office you know or was fixing to be he
hadn't hadn't been kicked out I believe
when I wrote that piece done dad said
don't worry we've got the perfect
candidate oh we got the man to replace
dick and we'll still be and we'll still
be in the White House we got it made now
and I say cousin there does that do you
mean John Connally who had just been
converted to a Republican hadn't been
indicted at that time
and he's a now sure don't mean John
Conlee done got in trouble no sir I mean
the man that nobody can put a hand down
he's a trained actor he ain't got much
his name is Ronnie Reagan from
California and I said all Ronald Reagan
Governor of California he hadn't got a
chance in the world great goodness Lobby
nothing but a movie actor he said that's
the whole point
he's a movie actor he don't say nothing
he never has said nothing that nobody
could remember so much as five minutes
but he's just the perfect person to
replace dick Nixon as cousinly it's not
very I think you also made a point that
story that all the other presents that
hadn't been actors but they just were
amateurs yeah now we're going to get
effects professor that's right you
already done your part in this book oh
it's wonderful it's wonderful you cost
it cost me a lot of sleep last night
y'all read why I had to read them again
and to a friend of mine and then keep it
going that's a real pleasure to hear
because you know when I got this thing
together it consists of a lot of the
pieces that I've written in the past and
lot of them that I did have done
verbally but have never brought us a
tires that did upon that pair Archer USA
where I take the about nine characters
nine different characters but I never
had written them out and apparently at
work because I got a letter today from
Tris coughing up in Washington DC and he
said he and his wife had been reading
them out loud to one another which I
found terribly flattering and it's real
nice they bring the characters to life
the dialects that you get into the
dialects are perfect you can just
imagine somebody saying them by reading
in that nice over here y'all did a lot
of research on this and your master's
thesis at the University of Texas which
under under Adobe was about what ten
black term then we grow sermons yes this
was just think this was forty five years
ago that I did
yeah no more than that forty said almost
a half-century ago I'd been studying
with Dobie I'd come to admire him a
great deal and in fact he was an
inspiration to me is a great man J Frank
Dobie for those of you that don't know
was a professor at the University of
Texas but he was also a writer and a
folklorist and one of the first persons
who turned my eyes he and Alan Lomax who
was a boy raised in Austin whose father
was a great folk law restricted to our
son
they turned my eyes back toward Texas
and our own culture and what we had
created here but the people of Texas
black and brown and white had created
here not not the names that are known
and recorded but the names that have
never been heard but the poetry and
music and the and the lovely lovely folk
stories and songs that they'd created I
got very excited over it and I realized
we were a cultured people we didn't have
to go to the Ivy League colleges to get
our culture that we had a country was a
different kind of culture but a rich
rich and so fulfilling one and that
turned me in turn toward the black
community that Austin at that time we
had a black family living on our place
and there were a great number of blacks
in Austin then but it was a segregated
segregated by law then and they it was
understood that blacks were to keep
their places but as a little boy I had
gone to their churches with my black
friends and heard their singing and knew
there was something unusual about it
when I got up from the Dobies class and
Bobby had been collecting folklore from
from his Mexican Vaqueros the Cowboys
the Mexican Cowboys down south takes the
songs and their stories and emphasized
the importance of this as a look at the
real texture of your society this is
where it is in those folk stories and in
those folk songs I got to tell them
about these some of the black friends
that I had and particularly the black
ministers you see most of them were
worked farmers they lived on farms and
many of them were almost completely
illiterate or just barely literate that
all of them had this gift of great folk
imagery and to evoke almost a mill tonic
image as they preached because the only
great literature they had ever
encountered was the Holy Bible and they
took it and rolled their own story and
their own hardships into it and they
knew all the characters of the Bible
they were personal friend with little
David no man Goliath and O'Daniel were
wandering around there and the wines
been and and I knew there was something
magnificent about it and so I went to
Dobby and told him about this black
friend Dobby was a man of prejudice by
the way he was very prejudiced about
blacks and about Mexicans a they were
where they were because that's where
they belonged in the order of things in
this guy he didn't challenge the
segregation or didn't challenge the any
of the racist and justices that existed
and were taken for granted then but any
rate I got telling about this black
Minister and he said and I quoted black
Minister who who the Sunday before it
said go down angel consume the flood
snuff out the Sun and turn the moon to
blood go down angel and close the dope
times have been shamed be no more and
Dobby said where is that man I said he's
out at that little church friendly with
a Baptist Church in South Austin he said
will you take me to hear him and from
that that was in 1935 from then on Dobby
took a very active interest and
encouraged me and that's how I came to
write my thesis 10 Negro sermons the
word Negro was where you designate if
you were progressive and enlightened
what you designated our black citizens
in otherwise you called them colored or
[ __ ] too very patronizing words
but I wrote these sermons I took these
sermons down verbatim and include two of
the men are in my book but you notice
that they're written in phonetically and
in dialect and I was very concerned over
that when my editor down at the Texas
Monthly who published this book it takes
in monthly press said look we want to do
them just the way you wrote them and I
said well that's that was fifty years
ago and that's the way you wrote black
speech then but it sounds too much like
Amos and Andy to suit me I'm
uncomfortable with letting these things
go out that way they said no we the
integrity of it is the important thing
and that's the way they were written and
that's the way you should do them if you
that's the way that should be published
in your book and that's the reason
they're written that way it's the only
way I could devise fifty years ago of
catching the cadence and the rich folk
imagery and the nuances and the zest
that I felt as I sat there and listen to
these magnificent men and with the
absolute milk tonic splendor preaching
in some little church it was leaning
sideways down the bottoms and no one at
this time you understand was collecting
this material folklore collecting was
not that was confined to their academic
exercise and confined to an esoteric few
at in the inner open academic community
in your book you also have a lot of
stories that are not political in nature
but just funnier in hell and for
instance like the Ben Rutledge story yes
can you tell us that way well Ben rut is
I have this imaginary town of that I
created called pear orchard Texas and
it's it's right there between everybody
knows where it is here in Texas it's
right between El Paso and Texarkana
and it's a regular Texas town and I have
nine I have nine or ten citizens that I
discussed there Liz I do their parts on
the stage and this one-man theater I did
and Ben Rutledge I Drive in he's one of
the first citizens I met there I drove
into two pear orchard two and as the
edge of town I came to this little
filling station grocery store and pulled
up to get directions down to the
courthouse and it was an unremarkable
filling station grocery store there was
a man leading sitting in a straight back
chair pushed back against the wall
dozing with his hat about half over his
face and in gravel-walk way there was a
little boy playing stick horse on a
double-barrel shotgun riding it's a
stick horse galloping up that and that
was very impressive as far as I was
concerned and so as I stopped at the gas
pump
I wasn't didn't won't guess this was
going to ask direction this man came
down in his chair I said wait no don't
get up mister I just want to get
directions I don't want gas and I can
give you directions heap cheaper and I
can give you gasoline and I said what
can you tell me how to get down to the
courthouse yes sir I sure can tell you
how to do down now you go down at their
third red light and Marvin honey Papa's
asked you not to ride that shotgun
around like that it ain't no stick
holocene ain't supposed to ride it like
that ain't nice little boys play with no
loaded shotgun that way the court you
can't miss court how far you swing right
that Papa at courthouse been sitting
there now since 1910 Papa help bill that
Papa with one the carpenter's own I say
1910 I could have been 1912 I
here or Marvin honey quit a staring down
the barrel of that shotgun you go blow
your head off in your mama where are you
at young man and I tell your old judge
Hawkins Estelle you just exactly when
that courthouse was built of course I
don't know what you're going there for
you might be going there to get you
divorced or get married you can't never
tell
Marvin honey don't be pointing the
shotgun if pop it ain't nice little boy
point loaded shotguns to Daddy now you
take that in the house and you put it up
on the I told you
Marvin baby don't be pointed at the man
in the car it makes people nervous to
point loaded shotguns at him yes it does
what do you think he's laying down in
that car like that for mr. mister don't
try to drive off like that laying down
that away mister mister he couldn't hit
you if he was to shoot at you mister he
ain't no shot at all mister I wouldn't
drive like it and when you get to that
third red light it might be green
that actually happened it's kind of a
modified but I love them I love well I
love the people of Texas actually
they're they're pretty good bunch of
people Jana I suspect that a lot of your
egalitarian nature comes from your
upbringing yeah you buddy to round a lot
with with colored people as well as way
you had some experiences with Snookie
Bates's at the nest that was daddy daddy
and Mama who are pretty remarkable
people I realized mama was school
teacher and interesting the enough she'd
born right down here whoever built Texas
just 12 miles from City Limits you know
and lived there and in Austin all her
life which was well over half a century
and so my roots ran pretty deep into
this culture but they were both
enlightened people my father has I said
had been a sharecropper but he learned
after he grown almost read and write and
then go to school at the University of
Texas and got his law degree just before
the turn of the century and became a
very successful lawyer here in town but
became a socialist in about nineteen 419
six ran for governor on a socialist
ticket here in Texas had a big so you
see this is what isn't known about Texas
and this is what aggravates me it's not
known that Texas had a rich progressive
background you know the Knights of Labor
were farmed here right the populist
party was a very prominent part of Texas
politics and that was a this is why
Dobby and better check in web excited me
so because they were out of that
tradition there were all three born and
raised in Texas yet there were three
more progressive minds ever created in
the United in the United States of
America and those three because when I
told you a minute ago that Dobby was a
racist
something of a racist when I first met
him in the 30s he also loathed and
despised Roosevelt he thought the New
Deal was going to recommend of given
jobs to bunch of trifling people that
didn't deserve them people ought to get
out and make the owner sound very much
like Oh Ronnie Reagan does now and like
Herbert Hoover did back there he doesn't
sound like a populist does it but Dobie
Dobie had that great gift that I'd like
to associate with America in the United
States of America the great gift of an
unfettered mind the liberated mind and
he learned and they wrought his horizons
broadened and broadened by the by the
month after we got to be friends and
better check who was really better
checked was really he's so little known
here in the state and yet he should be
the most prominent citizen
should rank up there ahead of Jim Hagen
Jimmy already was just a great great
mine my continent man was a classicist a
great socialist a great social thinker
and a gentleman and a poet and a and a
naturalist he'd leaned his ear were
close to the earth and he caught the
rhythms and the sounds of the Texas
earth and there wasn't a raw flower that
blossomed in all the state of Texas that
he couldn't identify instantly by its
perfume or by Satan there wasn't a wild
bird that nested anywhere in Texas he
couldn't identify in a twinkling this
was really better check and he had a
great influence on me and on doe BC he
was Dobies closest friend and he and I
would despair would o be some of Dobies
reactionary and rather backward
observations about race and that sort of
thing and and particularly about
Roosevelt because mr. Betterton cannot
both was very fond of what the New Deal
was trying to do it was from my point of
view and from Jake's point of view and
from Daddy's point of view this is rot
the American government was all about
what these men had found after all a
part of a part of our preamble says to
do not only to establish justice ensure
domestic tranquility provide for the
common defense promote the general
welfare this is the people's servant
doing its best to promote promote that
taking the responsibility for those that
are not fortunate this is what American
government should be about and Roosevelt
was bringing that into being well within
four or five years old
Dobby had come around to our point of
view and within ten years we were trying
to catch up
you know he was attacked during the
McCarthy period he was he had his his
passport denied him in 1952 he had a
teaching appointment in over in Ankara
American University in Ankara and to the
everlasting disgrace of the State
Department and that terrible terrible
error called the McCarthy period named
for Senator McCarthy Toby wasn't allowed
he was considered a danger to the United
States what a shocking thing what I
wanted to say in this book one of the
things I want to say is we're pretty
splendid people if we recognize what
makes us splendid
it's not the narrow bigoted in and the
reactionary that's not ever a period
that we periods that we brag about do
you all realize that in 1950 for the
first time in the history of the United
States the word treason was used in
political dialogue in our society to
attack a political opponent most
Americans don't realize that very few
very few even political commentators
realized that this was the first time it
was ever used to describe a political
opponent by McCarthy he said we'd lived
under 20 years of treason and old dick
Nixon echoed that you know they found
that paid off in political paydirt and
if you you can understand the poison of
it and how had a great cost it has been
to us and the American an American
society now in our society after all it
cost us the Vietnam War the Watergate
institutionalized secrecy in government
it had a terrible cumulative effect on
our society Henry in your book also
you not only have things that are you
know funny and a lot of political humor
and satire you have some serious stories
in there too
that really grip you because you catch
the color of him like the poor boy who
was given a orange for Christmas and
yeah so delighted because that's the
first orange well you know that's
another aspect of my life that I try to
get into the book is that the in I was
raised out in South Austin and people
from up in along Barton Creek and up in
the hills west of Austin that's now
become very fashionable residential area
but at that time nobody lived up there
but people who chopped wood for a living
the very poorest of our society lived up
there and he'd come down in the winter
and camp along creek below our house
down about a half a mile from our home
in the shabbiest and most desolating
kind of habitations are lived in lean
tubes with all their children and this
had a great impression on me I played
with my father was very tolerant very
very sympathetic with them because he'd
been raised pretty much that way himself
and so iris
naturally moved into a role of tolerance
with them they went to for more school
out in South Austin and always had a
faint scent of urine you know because
they slept in the same clothes that they
came to school in and it was a
heartbreaking but I was very early on
established a relationship with them
instance you're telling about our member
that's about 10 years old his little boy
Cole Cole Christmas morning a lot of
times not cold Christmastime in Texas
but it was a cold frosty morning and he
came running up to the house barefooted
in a pair overalls from down on the
creek where he left with an orange it's
just I went to the door and he's
standing there said look I told Santa
Claus brung me
his father had gotten it today before at
a shrine Christmas tree for the poor and
the needy and he said God better seen
answer that ain't no real Christmas gift
that's that's just the orange shoot that
ain't nothing special a little faith
fail you know and this is that's the
only Christmas present I ever got Johnny
and it they stuck there like a knife I
realized I said a terrible thing to that
child
well these experiences like that had a
also a very educational effect on me
also for the first time in your book I
noticed that you use the medium of a
blue jay as part of a little dialogue
between you and yourself
lester blue jay let's go blue LBJ got
attack yet how did you happen to pick
that with their eye I'd wanted to I'd
wanted to say something about the you
see we what we have never done and what
I realized and this was written during
the Vietnam War America wasn't looking
at what they were doing we in Vietnam
the cost to the Vietnamese people the
napalm the guy using using poisons to
the behaving in a way that Hitler would
have behaved and this appalled me
because I'm very proud of our society in
its heritage and I felt this was a
denigration and a negation of everything
that was decent about America to go over
there to a fourth-rate primitive country
agricultural country and care the latest
in death and desolation and we still
haven't looked at that by the way and so
in order to make a point
I used this blue Jay Lester blue jay
that would come around taunting me about
the in facility and the inhumanity
was being visited we the Vietnam War had
a very profound effect on me I thought
it was one of the most disastrous things
that had ever happened to us
brutal the brutalization of the American
because we had to watch it on television
see and to see our troops marching over
you know burning down the homes of these
people desolating their fields primitive
people people that were struggling and I
almost just to stay alive and we've
never really stopped and examined what
we did what a desolating terrible thing
we did over there to those be we still
have it today you know the boys left the
Agent Orange Agent Orange award from
these these chemical companies that
manufactured it to go over there and
spread it over that land they've won a
degree of sympathy and they've also won
a lawsuit they're being awarded
something some compensation for the
suffering of themselves and their
families for this Agent Orange that our
own government is too Don but what about
the millions of Vietnamese people who
had this poured on them in their homes
what about the disfigured children over
there today we don't even pay any mind
to him it's only we never were there we
still have a self-righteous pompous
behavior and to think that the President
of the United States would say this is
our it was a noble law nonsense this
10th anniversary we've just been
celebrating shame on us we got better
than that in us none of us have talked
about what we did to them we're talking
mostly about them is I have a great
sympathy for Vietnam veterans they did
get a shabby difficulty were set off to
her to a desolating experience that
shattered many of their lives and him
not you know recovered from it yet and
we did precious little for them and have
done precious little form but that's
that's not to say that we didn't also
visit death and desolation on those
people over there and they're doing the
same thing in Nicaragua and grenade yes
where it's say it almost almost it's
it's almost it was they had written a
scenario taking this scenario from
Vietnam and running it off in Nicaragua
and El Salvador now all based on this
this the coming is going to get you do
you know I've heard very distinguished
and intelligent Americans saying you
know at El Salvador if we don't stop
that what is it the Sandinistas air in
Nicaragua the federal there be other
borders do you realize was there more
people in Harris County Texas today than
there are in El Salvador and these
jackanapes are seeing they're about to
come over a border this is a you know
cousin it's not grace now he supports
the president in El Salvador a hundred
percent I've been in Central American
particularly in Nicaragua cousin it's
not you say that I say it is Ronnie
smaller Ronnie understands that
sandanista crowd down there and
everything going on in Nicaragua and I
back him 100%
do you realize they mayor sand in
Easter's you read so much about Ronnie
has read a book they're read he didn't
read the whole book but he did Reader's
Digest where that crowd of heathens is
Nicaraguans to Sandinistas ain't nothing
in the world but nickel are turns to now
what does that tell us about the sanity
stirs that they've had the audacity to
infiltrate their own country lowdown
infiltration this is where he
infiltrates yourself they're doing it
well he also believes that Grenada you
know he said oh did you hear President
Reagan say we got to Grenadier just in
time you know what he meant by that I'll
tell you what he meant by that they got
secret plans with em grenadiers had all
the plans brought up where they were
going to sweep up the Atlantic in
Pacific Coast and locked us in between
and every man woman child American half
sign their names they'd be a
marxist-leninist puppet all right be
Katie put the cat out oh that's what
that was I thank goodness for Ronnie
Reagan he does all this thinking first
well then that unfortunately is far more
accurate and I think my dear as far as
what the what was really said to justify
the biggest most powerful overwhelmingly
armed affluent society on the face of
the earth to going to the smallest
poorest island in the entire western
hemisphere an island less than hundred
thousand people and bogging in with six
thousand eight thousand troops that they
managed what they didn't there'd I don't
think they had over a thousand armed
resistors down their dead to just a few
hundred and six hundred and fifty or
seven hundred you've been Cuban workers
on their thing then this is obscene you
see this is this is a block this isn't a
matter of pride this should be a matter
of deep deep embarrassment shame to the
American people there's a book out you
have to read debt not just my booklet
there's not a mountain called oh it's an
English journalist that was there that
tells exactly what happened in grenade
have you seen it yes in Grenada uh-huh
and it really is a revelation because it
ain't what of course American people
have no idea what happened in Grenada
because the administration to its
everlasting disgrace shut the fresh out
for three days
and so that the American public knows
very much is the public in any
totalitarian society no only what the
government tells them they can know only
what is printed in new the official word
that that Washington gave you on things
so we never really knew what happened
and any American tells you he knew
exactly what happened out in grenade has
talked to his hat John Henry I'm in a
terrible dilemma here I'd like to
continue talking but I made you a
promise that we will go write it you all
have both been offer my so Craig listen
where are you from summit well I hate to
admit it but from New York well it's
good to have you down here I wish more
New Yorkers like you'd come down here
that's right help us out with John Henry
thank you so much am i holding this hold
it up again they're going to sell maybe
two or three well I'm dead we'd like to
say I'm back again
maybe all have been real sweet about it
I really appreciate it very very much
but other people can be most
appreciative people been watching I
always enjoy being on this program but
any rate cut head was telling me about
what a wonderful thing it was to have
Alexander Haig that profound think Iran
nuclear war he said John II know the
most misunderstood thing America day
nuclear war it's dangerous an average
American don't know just how dangerous
it is only person I really know that
understand nuclear war is Alexander Haig
you old liberals and you old weak minded
pussyfooting Democrats and all such as
that lay back and say well we can kill
their body and rush you twenty five
times that's plenty got enough nuclear
bombs to blow them all off face their 25
times and we're gonna rest on that they
can't kill us but twelve times
Jonnie that's where Alexander Hague's
great mind comes in he knows that you
have a first-class all-out nuclear war
and find out them Russians has secretly
slipped around and can kill us 30 times
and we still stuck back at 25 that's
what's next war is going to be about
it'll be too late to go round apologize
to bed eggs and ER Hague then he won't
even speak to you then and I jumped him
other day already he you know he jumped
me said Johnny I know you hear what
there's old students out the universe
for doing their protest in that fair
Grenadier war down there that Ronnie's
trying to run it's just disgusting
they get out there and they start that
protesting business and protesting
business I think they just ought to do
something to them I said no wait a
minute cousin it don't you believe in
the right to dissent of course I believe
in the right to defend I knocked a man's
teeth down his throat that did a fear of
my right to defend Ronnie believes in
the right to dissent what him and me try
to put a stop to is this criticism
criticize criticize criticize why can't
they leave Ronald Reagan alone let him
fight his Wars in peace they want to
criticize somebody let him go down there
and criticize oh Castro and that crowd
of ethan's Johnny we got fared a
Grenadier just in time oh my god you
don't understand what was going on
Ronnie does though do you know that
bunch of Rascals down there was planning
to attack us any morning they've got us
pinned in here between the Gulf of
Mexico and the Arctic Circle and gonna
come a sweeping in here like a dose of
salts through a widow woman throwing
guns down on us all of us and making us
sign our names to test papers and such
as that that we come that will be
Marxist Leninist or they won't let us up
again I'll tell you ronnie has just
saved America that's what he's done from
an invasion of them rascal I asked a
friend of mine it's a great champion of
the Reagan administration to explain
Ronald Reagan's foreign policy to me and
he says oh I'm glad you asked me then
let me tell you some honey it's just as
clear and simple as you please it's easy
to understand John tower senator tower
explained it to me the other day Johnny
it's this way I can tell you to you
because I can discuss it honestly you
know Ronald Reagan loves the truth and I
love the truth and I love to tell it in
that plain English the language the Holy
Bible was wrote in the language that old
mother of mine spoke I sometimes think
that Almighty and his divine wisdom when
he saw fit to create his most perfect
work here on earth selected Lone Star
State of Texas as paradise on earth
and he came to this Garden of Eden on
earth Travis County Texas and he caught
the goal from the Texas sunrise and he
caught the sweetest note from the throat
of the Texas I'll convert our state
birds and he caught perfume of the Texas
Bluebonnet our state fly and he
compounded it molded it all together
into that quintessence of sweetness and
that epitome of all virtue and goodness
my mother
when that Sun that's what Ronald
Reagan's foreign program is all about
and if you don't understand it fully
I'll explain it further your old man
Tom Taylor said Johnny the trouble with
the world today are that we have gone
and invented a way of wiping ourselves
off the globe and we done it before we
invented a way to stop ourselves from
doing it this is right where we are
today there is no alternative to peace
remember when Phil Graham stands up and
says I represent the best interest of
the people of the 6th congressional
district it's about like a big old
possibly end up in a hen house claiming
I represent the poacher buns association
in this sex what is happening in Austin
Texas as these brutal manipulating money
corporations they're not people you
understand a corporation isn't a person
yes people on Jefferson said it has no
it has no heart to feel d'Arnaud behind
the cake well a corporation there's a
faceless they that lives entirely for
profit and it can't consider the human
factor involved as it greedily devours
the earth as it destroys the society
John Henry I thank the people in Austin
run him out you know and we let him come
to Madison feel that is our second
mistake but somebody had to take him in
in a junior pardon told him he had a
good lake over and he'd make you manager
this lake and he said well never seen
the lake need somebody it phases over 40
record show me around and so I was the
one that was elected to go with him to
the leg I carried him over fishing one
day is in the spring of the year and
these water marks did just come out you
know and laying these little blood and
well the trees grow out over the lake No
big old boxes laying up in under there
and John Denver said no in the middle
and I was running the boat and I run it
up in understand with him bushes and
there's old watermarks and fell out in
the boat when the did John Henty come on
way out there and I just stepped out of
the boat and headed for the land he
hauled away Piedmont said don't leave me
here with this night I said well Johnny
enter this is that time you heard about
when three's a crowd on him John Henry
was always involved in something when he
seen somebody being mistreated or seen
some big corporation trying to force
some little man into something that he
didn't think was right with John Henry
was up taking his side in he he's always
been for the working man when Henry is a
real friend house in Leon County we were
in trouble here about two and a half
years ago with this nuclear waste
storage here in the on county and John
Henry came came up stood up with us
fought against the stupid waste here in
Leon County and also he went to Austin
with us to fight with us and fortunately
we were able to have a bill passed in
Austin made some strong restrictions on
the nuclear waste at this time we don't
we don't healthy you could waste here
but we felt like the fight to stay alone
and and I feel like the John Henry will
continue fight with us home call him you
bet I think John Henry would make a good
congressman I said do because he he's
always taking up and fighting somebody
to battle for him helping him he'll I
have owned several occasions seen John
Henry help people and when he didn't
have the time I've heard him say it any
other time meeting his home we had got
phone call people wanting to help him do
something he would talk to him and tell
him he'd help him
and after that hang up
he said boy I just you don't have the
time to do that but said I'm said
obvious got to help them little boy or
sit up so that I feel like I'd kind of
man that that will take his time and not
do what he really should be doing to
benefit yourself but he'll go and help
he'll help another man rather than race
soon first selling this I don't know
what will feel results but I'll always
feel good about what I did I've done
I've said to the people what I wanted to
say to a moan every issue that I felt
was important
and I'm very saddened by the 6th
congressional district being both high
for about man
of dollars behind this is a comment I'm
very sad commentary on our society